[Musik]
dafür ist der pro-kopf-verbrauch von
schokolade merken zwei ja-stimmen
endlich mittagspause aha merke ich mir
etwa ereignet
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen auf einem kanal
nehmen ich weiß nicht ob ich ihn schon
kennt aber der neue club hast muss
regelt er ist einfach unglaublich lecker
und ich finde sogar so viel besser als
das normale knopf und ich konnte es
nicht lassen und hab zu hause die xxl
variante gemacht
und dass das ganze so schwer ist das
möchte ich euch in diesem video zeigen
wir benötigen branche blätter die habe
ich bereits auf die maß 37 x 13
zurechtgeschnitten
außerdem etwas geschmolzene freundlich
kuvertüre und für die erste schicht
benötigen wir 400 gramm geschmolzene
weiße schokolade oder kuvertüre und 120
gramm gezuckerte kondensmilch
und da ich selbst leider keine kasten
backform habe die muss ich mich
schnellstens anlegen habe ich hier
einfach meinen eckigen backwaren
genommen und bin mir so zurecht gemacht
wie gerne hätte dann habe ich darunter
mein schneidebrett gelegt und das ganze
eingebettet und mit frischhaltefolie auf
begleitet diesen bug haben habe ich aus
dem online shop von fällig welt der ist
wirklich sehr zu empfehlen falls wir
aber eine kasten backform habt könnt ihr
natürlich sehr gerne verwenden
und nun legen wir los mit unseren
körpern und dafür machen wir zuallererst
den schoko boden dafür geben wir eine
dünne schicht geschmort mit privat türe
auf dem boden und verstreichen
auch die flüssige dünne schutzschicht
geben wir dann die erste waffel und
drücken sie leicht an
für die weiße schicht in unserem
knoppers nehmen wir unsere geschmolzenen
kuvertüre oder schokolade und geben da
die gezuckerte kondensmilch hinein da
die kondensmilch nicht erwärmt wurde
wird die creme relativ schnell hart ich
finde dass man so besser arbeiten konnte
wer dort aber nicht so gerne maske kann
die kondensmilch auch vorher gerne
erwerben
hier seht ihr das bekleben in
sekundenschnelle hart wird und die geben
wir dann sofort auf die waffe
[Musik]
könnte das dann entweder mit eurem
löffel rückens dateien oder was ich viel
besser fand mit den händen
ein weiterer vorteil ist hier dass wir
nicht warten müssen das system erkaltet
sondern sie ist noch fortsetzt und wir
können weitermachen wird der nächsten
schicht und hierfür gebe ich etwas
geschmolzen beweis unserer türe auf die
seite warum mit der ouvertüre nach unten
gehen wir die waffel jetzt auf die creme
schicht und dann gehts nun weiter mit
der schoko schick
dafür benötigen wir 600 gramm
geschmolzen vollmilch kuvertüre 200
gramm gehackte haselnüsse und acht
esslöffel nutella
wir werden einfach nur alle drei zutaten
gut miteinander verrührt und ich starte
mit der nutella gebe sieht das folglich
kuvertüre und verdammt gut miteinander
[Musik]
bei diesem rezept braucht die übrigens
keinerlei küchenmaschinen oder handvoll
geräte das geht alles mit löffeln und
schneebesen oder was du sonst
[Musik]
nun geben wir die haselnüsse mit ins
boot und verrühren das auch noch mal gut
miteinander und dann die nächste schicht
auch schon fertig
[Musik]
die kombination hat mich übrigens wer an
hannover erinnert also auch super lecker
wenn er einfach so machen möchte
aber wir müssen sie jetzt weiter
verwerten und bissigen dem wir sie auch
die waffel und streichen sie
anschließend schön glatt
programm
anschließend muss die zehn kalt werden
und im kühlschrank wird sie natürlich
schön hart ich gebe euch aber einen tipp
gibt das ganze doch ins gefrierfach dann
geht das zu schnell
in der zwischenzeit bereiten wir schon
mal das karamell vor
und hierfür benötigen wir 600 gramm
seiten 600 gramm traubenzucker 800 gramm
träsch und 400 gramm haselnüsse wir
geben zuerst kämpferisch und sogar in
unserem top wenn wir das ganze noch
nicht eingeschaltet sondern erstmal gut
miteinander verrührt
an der stelle habe ich mir gedacht
moment mal kritik am menschlichen körper
regel wie es doch ziemlich dick und
deswegen habe ich nochmal die zutaten
genommen die die ich euch erde genannt
hat die zutaten sind aber so korrekt
also noch mal alles gut miteinander
verrühren und dann gibt's gleich schon
weiter
[Musik]
nun wird der herd eingeschaltet da könnt
ihr euch die höchste stufe nehmen
ihr dürft aber nicht aufhören zu hören
also immer schön um das ganze auf
braucht
[Musik]
hier seht ihr dass die farbe sich schon
ein wenig verändert hat das land wieder
geworden und beim aufwachen hat das
ganze eine temperatur von 100 grad an
der stelle schalten wir den herd runter
auch mittlere stufe und geben den deckel
drauf
[Musik]
mai
an schicken lassen wir die masse auf 135
grad erhitzen wenn dann lösen sich die
zuckerkristalle auf und dann haben wir
perfekte per mail wer kein thermometer
für handhabt das ganze hat bei mir
sicher 30 minuten gedauert ich hab euch
die zeit gestoppt und in das karamell
gebe ich dann die haselnüsse nachdem ihr
die dann auch gut untergehoben habt ist
unsere letzte schicht des knopfes
riegels fertig
die schoko haselnuss krems auch schon
gut durch gehärtet und jetzt geben wir
das karamell drauf und verstreichen dass
gerd dieser stelle muss ich noch vor
waren dem terramail ist wirklich sehr
heiß also wenn ihr euch sicher seid dann
lasst euch von niemandem helfen oder
lasst das ganze ein wenig abkühlen
[Musik]
nachdem also die letzte schicht auch
schön glatt gestrichen wurde kommt der
regel noch ein letztes mal ins
tiefkühlfach
[Musik]
ich habe ihn ca 2 stunden im tiefkühler
und wenn ihr dann soweit seit und euer
regel richtig schön kalt ist bei ihnen
auf entweder zwei oder drei gläser oder
ich hatte zufällig eine schöne
rechteckige form dar
und dann kommt nur noch die geschmolzene
völlig overture drauf wenn ihr euch
jetzt fragt aber knie warum hast du denn
nicht die form benutzt für den regeln
das war mir noch viel zu klein denn wenn
ich schon xxl macht dann so richtig
nachdem wir dann die geschmolzene freue
mich kuvertüre auf das knoppers gegeben
haben wird das ganze mit unserer winkel
palette schön verstrichen
mit diesem schritt habe ich sicher 800
gramm freue mich kuvertüre geschmolzen
ich schreibe euch übrigens alle zutaten
und alle genauen mengenangaben immer in
die infobox
dann habe ich mit meiner dünnen winkel
palette noch das schöne muster oben
drauf gemacht so wie es auch im original
zu sehen ist und dann muss das ganze
noch durch kühlen und ihr habt geschafft
die und knox ist endlich fertig
[Musik]
und ich hab euch ja schon anfang
verraten dass ich den knopf muss regel
viel leckerer finde als das normale
knopflers um mich würde interessieren
welche variante er bevorzugt habt ihr
den knopf muss regel denn überhaupt
schon probiert und erzählt mir unbedingt
wenn jemand xxl variante ausprobiert hat
falls euch das video gefallen hat freut
mich sehr über einen daumen nach oben
und überall wo damit ihr auch keines
meiner vor allem xxl videos mehr
verfasst bis zum nächsten mal auf die
skizzen
[Musik]